WITH KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
THE HOUSE ON THE HILL JUST
PASSED THE BILL, WHICH SEEMS
LIKE A BIG DEAL.
STILL, THE MEDIA HAS DECIDED
IT’S BEEN A BAD YEAR FOR TRUMP.
AS THE YEAR ENDS, THEY HACKED MY
SLICED TOGETHER THEIR ANNUAL
SCORECARDS.
THEY CONFIRM TRUMP DID BADLY.
WELL, EXCEPT FOR ISIS.
GETTING RID OF VICES, THAT’S A
GOOD THING.
WE DESTROYED MODERN-DAY NAZIS.
TERRIBLE, THE ECONOMY.
BEYOND THAT.
THE NEW ENERGY POLICY, PIPELINE
DRILLING, FRACKING.
GAS PRICES FLAT AS A PANCAKE.
I’M TELLING YOU.
IT IS STILL OF BAD YEAR.
I WOULD HATE TO BE TRUMP.
HE HAS NO SINGULAR ACHIEVEMENTS.
OKAY, THERE IS THE TAX BILL.
BUT IT’S BEEN A LOUSY YEAR.
EXCEPT FOR THE IMPROVED
RELATIONS WITH CHINA AND RUSSIA,
INDIA, THE SAUDIS, ISRAEL.
BUT IT’S BEEN A DOWNER.
DID I LEAVE ANYTHING OUT ASIDE
FROM DEREGULATION, REPEALING THE
MANDATE, DRIVING ENIMEM NUTS.
THAT’S KIND OF AWESOME.
WHEN COMPILING YOUR
CONDEMNATIONS, IT’S HARDER THAN
IT LOOKS.
WHAT STARTED OUT AS EVIL WAS
DOWNGRADED TO INCOMPETENT, AND
NOW IT LOOKS PRETTY DAMN
EFFECTIVE.
NO WONDER THE MEDIA LOOKS SO SA
SAD.
INTERESTING FACT I LEARNED
TODAY, DANA.
THEY ARE DOING A REVOTE OF THE
BILL TOMORROW.
>> Dana: IT’S A TECHNICAL
GLITCH BECAUSE THERE ARE THREE
PROVISIONS IN THE G.O.P. TAX
BILL THAT THE SENATE -- THEY
HAVE TO REALIGN THE BILLS AND
IT’S A TECHNICAL THING.
THERE IS NO PROBLEM.
THE TAX BILL.
>> Greg: THEY HAVE TO GET THE
BILLS IN LINE.
ALL RIGHT.
BIG DEAL?
>> Kimberly: I THINK IT’S A
BIG DEAL.
THIS IS THE SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN WORKING HARD
ON.
HE’S BEEN TALKING TO
CONSTITUENTS IN TRYING TO GET
SUPPORT.
THEY WERE ANXIOUS TO GET GOOD
LEGISLATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
PRIOR TO THE CLOSE OF THE YEAR,
ESPECIALLY WITH CHRISTMAS.
THIS CAN ONLY BE VIEWED AS
POSITIVE.
ITS STEPS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
HE SEEMS TO BEEN ABLE TO
COALESCE SOME GOOD BROAD-BASED
SUPPORT EVEN FROM PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN TRADITIONALLY
SUPPORTED OR HIS LEGISLATION.
IN THAT SENSE, YES.
IT’S ALSO IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT’S
ONE OF THE MAIN CAMPAIGN
PROMISES THAT HE MADE WHEN HE
WENT ACROSS THIS COUNTRY TO TRY
TO ENGENDER SUPPORT FOR HIS
MOVEMENT, FOR THE WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN HE SAID WERE LEFT
BEHIND.
SAD, LISTEN TO ME, I WILL GIVE
YOU RELIEF.
YOU WILL FEEL IT AND SEE IT AND
WILL BE SOMETHING THAT’S
TANGIBLE FOR YOUR FAMILY.
>> Greg: JESSE, I’M GOING TO
PLAYERS AND SOUND FROM
NANCY PELOSI.
>> Jesse: WHY DO YOU HAVE TO?
>> Greg: IT IS THE ONE THING
YOU HATE MORE THAN SPEED METAL.
LET’S ROLL.
>> THIS IS THE WORST BILL TO
EVER COME TO THE FLOOR OF THE
HOUSE.
WITH STIFF COMPETITION FOR WHAT
SOME OF THE THINGS THEY TRIED TO
DO.
THE WORST BILL IN HISTORY.
>> Greg: JESSE.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE ALL THE
WORST BILL, ANYTHING THE
REPUBLICANS DO.
I’M GOING TO CHANGE MY GRADE
FROM A FEW WEEKS AGO ON THE
ELECTION.
I GAVE HIM A B+ ON DOMESTIC
POLICY.
WITH THE TAX BILL, I’M GOING TO
A.
IMAGINE WHAT HE WOULD BE DOING
IF THE MEDIA WASN’T 90% NEGATIV
NEGATIVE.
ECONOMIC OPTIMISM RIGHT NOW IS
THROUGH THE ROOF.
5,000-POINT GAIN IN THE DOW.
THAT’S A START.
I THINK AMERICA IS GETTING OVER
THE GREAT RECESSION HANGOVER.
TRUMP IS LIKE THE GATORADE AND
THE BACON EGG AND CHEESE WE NEED
AFTER THE HANGOVER.
YOU ALWAYS SAY WHAT HAS TRUMP
DONE TO CHANGE YOUR LIFE?
HERE’S AN EXAMPLE.
I THINK A THIRD OF AMERICANS
HAVE 401(K)s AND THE AVERAGE
HAS ABOUT $100,000 IN IT.
JUST IN THE FIRST YEAR ALONE, BE
TRUMP ECONOMY WOULD’VE MADE YOU
AN EXTRA $25,000 FOR YOUR
401(K).
THAT’S A LOT OF MONEY.
NOT ONLY THAT JOBS ARE UP, WAGES
ARE UP SLIGHTLY.
GAS PRICES ARE FLAT.
HOME OWNERSHIP IS UP.
SAFETY AND SECURITY.
NOT BRINGING IN THESE RISKY
REFUGEES.
THE ISIS CALIPHATE IS DESTROYED.
BORDER CROSSINGS ARE DOWN.
MS-13 PROSECUTIONS ARE UP.
THE SOCIAL ISSUES WHICH THE
LIBERALS LOVE TO TALK ABOUT.
GAY MARRIAGE IS STILL LEGAL.
ABORTIONIST ILLEGAL.
MEDICAL MARIJUANA, RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA.
STATES THAT HAVE THAT STILL HAVE
IT.
THE TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME I
BELIEVE IS SELF-INFLICTED.
THE FEAR AND LOATHING THE MEDIA
PUMPS UP IS A SCAM IN ORDER TO
KEEP HIS POLL NUMBERS DOWN.
AND TO HELP THE DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU LOOK AROUND, TRUMP HAS
BEEN GOOD FOR AMERICA AND
AMERICANS.
>> Greg: THE VAST MAJORITY ARE
GOING TO GET A TAX BREAK.
THAT MUST DESTROY YOU INSIDE,
JUAN.
>> Juan: THIS IS SO
RIDICULOUS.
I HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO LISTEN TO
YOU GUYS ANYMORE.
>> Greg: I KNOW THE FEELING
WITH YOU.
>> Juan: IT IS UNBELIEVABLE
THE WAY YOU PUT LIPSTICK ON A
PIG.
>> Greg: GREAT LINE.
HAVEN’T HEARD THAT BEFORE.
>> Juan: LET’S THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE TO
SAY.
THE POLLS SAY 32% APPROVAL FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: THEY DON’T HAVE TO
LIKE IT.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT THE TAX
BILL?
55% OF AMERICANS OPPOSE IT.
66% SAY IT IS HELPING ONLY THE
WEALTHY.
>> Greg: BECAUSE THE MEDIA HAS
DISTORTED IT.
HOW CAN YOU ARGUE THE TAX
BREAKS?
>> Juan: YOU ARE COUNTING
CRUMBS WHILE THE CAKE IS GOING
TO THE 1%.
THEN YOU SAY G, WHAT’S WRONG
WITH YOU?
LITTLE PEOPLE, CELEBRATE OUR
DEAR LEADER.
>> Jesse: AT LEAST THEY GOT
CRUMBS.
OBAMA JUST TOOK THE WHOLE CAKE.
>> Juan: I CAN’T BELIEVE THIS.
[ALL SPEAKING]
AT LEAST TWO LITTLE PEOPLE GOT
CRUMBS.
>> Jesse: THE VOTERS BROUGHT
AN REPUBLICANS TO GIVE THEM SOME
OF THEIR HARD-EARNED MONEY BACK
AND YOU DON’T WANT THEM TO HAVE
IT.
>> Juan: YOUR CONDESCENDING
ATTITUDE TOWARDS THE AMERICAN
>> Jesse: THE MIDDLE-CLASS
CUTS AVERAGED DURING DURING THE
OBAMA YEARS.
>> Juan: LET ME PICK ON
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE.
KIMBERLY, YOU SAID --
>> Kimberly: THAT’S A FIGHT
YOU’RE GOING TO LOSE.
>> Juan: YOU SAID DONALD TRUMP
SAID TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE I’M
NEVER GOING TO FORGET YOU.
I AM STANDING UP FOR THE
FORGOTTEN MAN AND WOMAN IN THE
COUNTRY, WORKING CLASS PEOPLE.
>> Kimberly: THAT’S WHAT I
SAID.
>> Juan: IT WAS A POPULIST
BILL.
IT’S A HUGE FAILURE EVEN BY THAT
STANDARD.
>> Kimberly: BOTTOM LINE: YOU
CAN SAY THAT ALL YOU WANT.
SHAPE SHIFT.
>> Juan: I AM JUST MAKING
STUFF UP.
>> Kimberly: OKAY, SOMETIMES.
IT DOES PROVIDE ECONOMIC RELIEF
AND TAX CUTS FOR THE MAJORITY OF
MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILIES.
HERE’S THE THING.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO GET
THIS CAMERA MAY BE THE EARLY
PART OF NEXT YEAR, FEEL SOME OF
THE BENEFIT AND IT’S GOING TO BE
TANGIBLE AND YOU’RE GOING TO SEE
THE NUMBERS GO UP IN THE
POLLS.
IF HE WAS WORRIED ABOUT POLLING
I THOUGHT IT WAS SO
DETERMINATIVE, HE WOULD’VE
THOUGHT HE WAS NEVER GOING TO
WIN BACK THE PRESIDENCY.
HE’S DOING IT BECAUSE IT’S THE
PROMISED AND HAS INTEGRITY AND
HE CARES ABOUT MAKING AN
ECONOMIC IMPROVEMENT.
RECORD NUMBERS, LOOK AT THE DOW.
>> Juan: OBAMA DID BETTER IN
HIS FIRST YEAR IN TERMS OF THE
STOCK MARKET’S PERFORMANCE.
OBAMA DID BETTER LAST YEAR IN
TERMS OF JOB CREATION THEN TRUMP
HAS DONE THIS YEAR.
HERE IS SOMETHING FROM
NANCY PELOSI, JESSE’S FAVORITES.
83% OF THE BENEFITS OF THIS TAX
BILL GO TO THE TOP 1%.
IN FACT, 60% GO TO THE --
>> Jesse: WHAT YOU CALL A
CRUMB MIGHT LOOK LIKE A CRUMB
FROM YOUR LOFTY PERCH,
MULTIMILLIONAIRE JUAN WILLIAMS
BUT THE REAL HARDWORKING
AMERICANS, IT’S MORE MONEY IN
THEIR POCKET.
IT’S THEIR MONEY, NOT YOURS.
>> Juan: THAT’S WHY IT’S GOING
TO THE CORPORATIONS.
>> Greg: WHY ARE YOU SO
WORRIED ABOUT THEM GETTING
CRUMBS?
THE GOVERNMENT STILL NEEDS IT.
I WANT TO MOVE ON.
>> Juan: YOU DON’T CARE THAT
THE RICH GET EVERYTHING.
>> Greg: WE ARE EVIL.
RICH PEOPLE ARE EVIL.
I GET IT.
>> Jesse: RICH PEOPLE PAY A
LOT OF THE TAXES AND THEN
THERE’S A TAX CUT AND THEY GET
TO PROPORTIONALLY KEEP MORE
MONEY.
>> Juan: DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
FRENCH CALL IT?
>> Jesse: JUAN, WE DON’T SPEAK
FRENCH IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Greg: I WANT TO GET DANA IN
HERE.
>> Kimberly: IF SHE CAN HEAR
ANYMORE.
>> Greg: THE YEAR-END STORIES
IN THE MEDIA, EMOTION VERSUS
REALITY.
THIS IS SARAH SANDERS GOING OVER
THE ACHIEVEMENTS TODAY.
>> NEARLY 1.7 MILLION NEW JOBS
HAVE BEEN CREATED IN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HAS FALLEN TO
4.1%, THE LOWEST RATE IN 17
YEARS.
THE STOCK MARKET REACHED A
RECORD HIGH, MORE THAN 60 TIMES.
WE FINALLY SET UP OUR NATION ON
THE PATH TO NOT ONLY ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE BUT ENERGY
DOMINANCE.
WE’VE SEEN THE LOWEST LEVEL OF
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS ON
RECORD.
JUSTICE GORSUCH WAS CONFIRMED TO
THE SUPREME COURT, AND THIS
EVENING, HOPEFULLY UPON PASSAGE
OF THE TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT,
THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE
DELIVERED THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
TAX CUT IN THE HISTORY OF THE
NATION AND REPEALED THE
OBAMACARE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
>> Greg: DANA, A PERSON MAY
NOT LIKE THOSE THINGS BUT THOSE
THINGS HAPPEN.
YOU ARE SEEING IN HEADLINES, MY
THEORY, PEOPLE ARE SHIFTING AWAY
FROM AWFUL TO ALL RIGHT,
BETTER-THAN-EXPECTED.
HE ACTUALLY GOT SOME STUFF DONE,
WHICH IS HARD FOR PEOPLE TO DO.
>> Dana: I THINK SHE MAKES A
COMPELLING CLOSING ARGUMENT.
SHE COULD DO IT WITH A LITTLE
MORE JOY.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY HAVE A GOOD STORY TO TELL.
THERE IS SOMETHING STRANGE ABOUT
THE PUBLIC’S MOOD WRIT LARGE AND
WHAT’S ACTUALLY HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND.
I THINK IF YOU WERE TO TAKE THIS
BACK TO THE FIGHT BETWEEN
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS AND
THE NEW TRUMP REPUBLICANS,
ACTUALLY ALL THOSE THINGS, IF
YOU ARE TRADITIONAL REPUBLICAN,
YOU ARE LOOKING AT THAT AND
THINKING PRETTY GOOD.
I THINK THE PERSONNEL CHANGES
THAT HAPPENED IN THE NINTH MONTH
OF AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER HAVE
CHANGED THINGS IN TERMS OF TONE
AND DEMEANOR.
>> Greg: INTERESTING POINT.
>> Dana: THERE IS THIS LAG.
THE FIRING OF JAMES COMEY, WHICH
LEADS TO THE SPECIAL CONSOLE
WHICH LEADS TO EVERY DAY TALKING
ABOUT RUSSIA, THAT IS SOMETHING
I THINK IS A DRAG ON THEIR
ABILITY TO TELL OTHER STORIES
WITH JOY.
>> Greg: THERE IS AN LAG, I
HATE TO PHRASE IT ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS.
THERE’S A FEUD GOING ON RIGHT
NOW BETWEEN CHARLES COOK AND
OTHERS OVER THIS.
THE HATE FOR TRUMP IS SO STRONG
THAT THEY CAN’T ACTUALLY MODIFY
JUST A LITTLE BIT AND SEE THAT
THEY ARE FOR A LOT OF THE THINGS
HE GOT DONE.
>> Kimberly: RIGHT.
THEY HAVE AN INHERENT BIAS IN
TERMS OF DISLIKING THE
INDIVIDUAL.
TO BE ABLE TO SEPARATE THE
SENDER FROM WHAT YOU ARE
ACTUALLY RECEIVING.
LOOK AT THE TANGIBLE BENEFITS.
I HAVE SEEN OUTLIERS, MORE OF A
COALITION SUPPORTING THE TAX
BENEFITS AND WITH THE PRESIDENT
IS TRYING TO DO.
I FIND THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE
ENCOURAGING.
>> Dana: CAN I ADD ONE THING
ON THAT, SINCE I WAS SO CALM
EARLIER.
AT ONE POINT, EARLIER IN THE
YEAR YOU HAVE THE FIGHT BETWEEN
RYAN AND TRUMP.
TODAY WHAT HAPPENED ON THE HOUSE
TAX BILL.
YOU HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
NUMBER ONE AGENDA FROM HIS
CAMPAIGN FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF
HIS PRESIDENCY MEET UP WITH PAUL
RYAN’S LIFELONG CAREER GOAL, AND
THEY ACTUALLY GET IT DONE IN
THAT FIRST YEAR.
THAT’S SOMETHING THEY CAN GO
HOME AND TALK ABOUT BUT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO    TO GOE
AND TALK ABOUT IT TOO.
>> Juan: IMAGINE THE 2018
ELECTION.
EVERY REPUBLICAN, EITHER THE
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICAN OR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SHIFTED, GREGORY
GOT FELLED, TO BECOME TRUMP
REPUBLICANS, THEY ARE ALL TRIED
TO TRUMP NOW.
WITH THIS TAX BILL, EVERY
DEMOCRAT RUNNING NEXT YEAR IS
GOING TO SAY OH, YOU PASS THIS
BILL FOR THE RICH.
>> Greg: I LOVE THAT YOU
DIDN’T SAY "GUESS WHAT."
>> Jesse: IT’S A LOSER BECAUSE
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLLING, THE
FIRST TIME IN OVER A DECADE
MAJORITY SAY THE ECONOMY IS GOOD
OR EXCELLENT.
A HISTORIC RECORD NOW SAY THE
ECONOMY WILL IMPROVE THE NEXT
YEAR.
YOU SEPARATE THEIR FEELINGS FOR
TRUMP AND THEIR FEELINGS FOR THE
ECONOMY, THINGS ARE GOOD ON THE